okay I believe this game town at carat
and a cream mmm and it had just get into
it if I can lab a [ __ ] [ __ ] someone's
like cheering ounce of them could be
carrots but I don't see it so I can't
quite tell [ __ ] is this okay get ya okay
um ISS hating his carrots okay I almost
got it oh um okay oh I got that carrot
oh ok I think it's a carrot dating yet
but I've got and got that one okay oh
it's another carrot we have to get out
this there's a carrot here okay good
good um okay I got this one um anything
oh so here's another one oh good good
good um okay and i think i had the same
particular this um oh ooh there we go we
got it we got this really no no worries
here oh I think we got enough carrots I
guess how could we got a lot of these um
okay i'll just read nice carrots you
know just try to put it in here okay
good good good you know this is going
very well I have to admit though this
isn't my first time um so if you think
it's just like beginners are like I'm
actually great like it's not sure like
dumbest see as I am trying to just do
this here now if it's a milk over there
cash reading
having I can't get get get the shredding
I can't get up get it okay and I would
have this that's a bigger carrot but I
think I could take it and need to shred
a stance had that you know I it's also
important make sure the pieces are God
you know like okay good good that's
enough I think they leaving an extra one
now it says over here oh ok oh oh no
okay I gotta get that carrot you know
like I gotta get there oh don't worry
don't worry you know like I was way
ahead of the game there uh oh good god
so like carrot you know okay I keep
little odd oh don't make sure I don't
get hit by that thing you know okay God
good um we were really bad if we got hit
by that thing you know I'm just like a
little worm you know I don't really need
to be on anyone's that side I'm just I'm
just here to be our worm you know I
tried to my thing hurry along here just
in case Oh some more where there's some
more character over there I gotta get
there jay is like I'm just nibbling like
you know I don't really I don't mean to
cause any harm I'm just here for the
carrots Oh chiz character getting kind
of farm between but what did that does
that hit can't is decaying carrot need
to get there I really need to just get
in there I race [ __ ] though where it
goes
okay oh sorry just shredding you know oh
wait did the little guy go in there I
don't know I'm really not sure hope he's
not in there oh well you know like oh he
isn't there okay well I guess he's okay
well I'm sorry like big like you know
okay we're leaving O'Neill oh ok um all
right well now that we try to make a
good carrot soup but someone's got away
that's funny yes yes